[Music]
as the work from home trend continues
there's a good chance many of you are
thinking about some upgrades around the
house cnet's dan ackerman is here to
help our resident tech guru has some
smart home tech that could help you save
some money and make your day a little
bit brighter and he brought in what else
a toaster
a toaster he's gonna go smart home you
gotta start with the small things little
appliances what does he do all right
listen i'm not going to lie you don't
need a smart toaster but if you're going
to get one they're kind of fun this is
the revolution instaglo and i love that
it has this big giant touchscreen on the
side very bright and then you pick what
you're doing you can get a waffle you
can get regular toast and then you
select how dark you want it
it's a pop-tart set oh you can go you
can go super dark if you're a maniac or
you can just go uh you know regular for
us as normal folks okay well just put
the bread in half wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
would you bring it
i got some bread
around no this is for real wait i'm
going to go to the setting for that look
i have a setting this is my this is my
normal toast at home i wanted
i'm not saying this is going to be any
better but you get to see a picture i
have a 25 toaster on my account i'm
going to go
middle on that how about that okay i'm
going to hit the button oh there it goes
look at that and then we just got the
timer the timer's going to go down and
we'll come back all right
all right so let's move along you got a
gadget that can help us start our day
with some sunshine um so what do you got
for us okay i always wanted smart blinds
to me that sounds like a great idea they
just go up automatically we're not quite
there yet this switchbot however
connects to your curtains like a little
robot and it just pulls them this way
pulls them that way you can have your
alexa do it you can do it on an app and
you just throw a couple of these on and
we're not in the future where all the
blinds are perfect and smart and
everything but this is a good
intermediate step and i love the concept
all right so we're spending money can we
save money with that plug over there i
use these on everything in my house
that's not already a smart device this
is a tp-link smart plug a lot of
companies make these you just plug your
device into this plug this into the wall
and then again alexa or your google
assistant or your app can turn stuff off
and on a lot of these had energy
monitoring built in so you can see from
an app on your phone how much power
you're using and if you go outside and
leave stuff on you can just tell it oh
turn off that light turn off that uh you
know electronic thing i left plugged in
that's an upgraded clapper
it's kind of like
that's a verbal clapper you just go
alexa do the
tapper
so so what do we got on the toast here
uh
we're still counting down okay so um do
you recommend the amazon blink outdoor
security camera you know i think we're
making a lot of progress here in these
cameras indoor ones outdoor warns used
to have to if you wanted the doorbell or
a camera you had to wire it in and that
was a that was a no-go for a lot of
people now they're wireless and you can
put a couple of batteries in this last
for like two years you could pop it up
in your batteries just put some
double-sided tape on the back stick it
anywhere
yeah
i don't know
listen i i gotta i get placed up in the
country and bears come and go through
the garbage occasionally and i literally
got this to put outside i have no idea
so you can sit in your office like
scarface and have cameras everywhere
just looking at it you have to do that
that's one way to use this i'm just
looking out for the bears okay is the
toast ready yet
it smells delicious it does smell really
good you said this is something you
might not need but this is about one
these these items are about want you
want to upgrade you know it's a small
indulgence a small luxury and then you
go i've got a smart toaster what is this
setting you back
um okay this is where it gets a little
four hundred bucks four hundred and
again again but look at that cool color
touch screen
and it's got waffle mode it does have
watermelon it smells like it's brown
what setting did you have that on yeah
you got that one i got a little
aggressive okay yeah i'm gonna pop that
up because i think you got that no no no
no no no no no no no final smarter
all right it's so smarter than me it's
better than all of us and those devices
over there how much is that these are
about 80 90
so 15 20
these are about 70 to 100 bucks oh we
got to pop it now we got five check it
out four no three wait wait wait wait
two
i don't know if it's better than my uh
30 toaster i don't know if it's better
than my target toaster my 25 oscars but
look at the moles though yeah bread
waffles yeah pop-tarts yeah all kind of
stuff moving free mode i thought we were
doing a countdown a gluten free oh you
were counting down the toast the toaster
i thought you know what i'm not even
going to commercial that's why i was
driving across can i show you something
yes yes okay you have this puppy right
okay to do its thing you know for
nothing what is it 80 bucks or nothing
how about that yes yes
a spouse
is good sometimes you just want a little
technology help to open your heart dan
ackerman you are the best you are so
much for stopping by we will be right
back